Remember that we've actually started talking about digital image is a function.
And this is something we've covered in the previous set of sub-lectures.
What I have introduced in those lectures is that we can actually talk
about an image basically as a function with we can actually look at an x and
y axis with the intensity in the third dimension.
That has allowed us to create images, or looking at images like this one,
the mandrill image we have looked at before.
And the bottom line of all of this has been that we want to be able to
represent an image as a matrix.
Where we can now traverse through this matrix in discreet Indices i and
j to be able to get any kind of value that we would be interested in to then for
example extract content.
And for example look at, the intensities at specific values, and
do some sort of processing with it.